till you get that good one I was
chatting to the man them today in the
what's that group and it was like well
you could even remember was saying about
a man dressing well you could tell when
I imagine dressing a certain way in a
relationship and out of a relationship
you can tell obviously I don't know
Magnum guitar I don't know if women can
tell but really the most like Dependable
like responsible man I know don't really
need a woman to like look after them not
to be honest it's not about need it's
about guidance so like I mean did you
get what I'm saying no because I'm just
thinking about the men like I respect
the most in my life that are really like
doing stuff um like I think of my dad
some of my brothers they don't need a
woman to like guide them or take care of
them they kind of have a path stuff they
want to do they don't really don't